notre manière de s'occuper c'est de
cultiver son jardin les français aiment
ça selon une enquête de l'insee 55 % des
ménages ont un jardin et s'ils n'en ont
pas ils rêvent d'en avoir
c'est possible même en ville la preuve
avec ce reportage des bété et patrick
descheemaecker
il habite à une demi-heure à pied 10
minutes en voiture
jean et jacqueline dit l'agent ici 200
mètres carrés de terres pour eux pour
biner sarcler arrosée et soigner leurs
légumes le soir bonjour surtout aux
mamans de ramassage les haricots verts
ont passé combien de temps dans ce
jardin dans la semaine bon maintenant
mois passent deux heures par jour mais
lui tout en allongeant charbit pu moi
j'ai fini je suis à la retraite c'est
pour ça que j'avais qu'une petite balle
de loisirs bleus mais c'est comme être
mais je passais à la retraite et en
commun comme comme dirait automne
or la gauche munich mais d un petit peu
comme seul espoir ou non toute la nuit
alors les oignons jaunes pour l'année
l'échalote journée pour l'année enfin le
respect du tout ça ça mijote toi on est
content mais si à l'oseille l'égorger ça
parle de quoi
cette raison n'achetez jamais de
congères
oh là là mon dieu on a mangé le matin
midi et soir comme on aurait emploi a
donné autour du jardin des deals âge 85
autres familles ont une parcelle de la
même taille 200 mètres carrés chacun
l'ensemble a été conçu il ya quatre ans
dans un projet de parc départemental
chaque parcelle est allouée 900 francs
par an vous pouvez croire comme le rôle
qu aucun mal pour trouver jardiner le
rêve croît deux foix plus de jardins et
de rêves candidats ce soir
pas de visite au supermarché l'édile
ajoncs pour dîner salade de tomates et
oignons pommes de terre sautées et
framboises du jardin